feminism goes out the [__] window the
second that the snow needs shoveling or
there's a broken down car or the tire
needs changing then all that crap
vanishes it's garbage and this is the
actual very interesting thing I'll make
a point here which is gonna be canceled
again but I don't give a [__] but
by the people who believe in it this is
what the whole point of war is this on a
time it doesn't matter if it's the
Christians against the Hindus it doesn't
matter if it was the Germans against the
French there were people who had ideas
and ideologies and they're prepared to
fight each other to defend their
ideology feminism is an ideology which
cannot be defended by feminists the only
people who could defend feminism are The
Men Who subscribe to the garbage if you
if you're all the feminists were to get
in a line and say we want feminism and
the conservative men were to get in a
line you will learn very quickly it's
[__]